ich habe die perfekte Pasta bei einer
italienischen Nonna gefunden schon seit
einem halben Jahr reise ich in geheimer
Mission durch Italien um die perfekte
Pasta zu finden ich habe in unglaublich
guten Restaurants gegessen Produktion
besichtigt Pasta verkostet und letzten
Endes habe ich sie bei einer
italienischen Nonna gefunden
erstklassige italienische Zutaten
Gelerntes Handwerk und eine Geheimzutat
amore durch die Verbindung von all dem
wird die Pasta zu einer echten Poesie
und vielleicht fragt ihr euch warum ich
all das gemacht habe ich will jedem von
euch die Möglichkeit ben in Genuss von
echter italienischer Pasta zu kommen und
zwar genauso wie die Nonna sie kocht
deshalb habe ich Pasta poesia geschaffen
italienische Pasta italienische Soßen in
5 Minuten bei dir zu Hause zubereitet
und deshalb kann ich sagen